so here's a challenge for you what about
this sequence 0 0 1 1 2 3 7 21 49 what's
the next number I'm gonna get a 73 no
I'm just guessing of course and you know
if any ordinary person would have no
clue that seemed like a totally vacuous
ears and I tell you it's 165 says why on
earth it 165 this is the number of
different mathematical knots with a
given crossing number basically it means
there are no mathematical knots these
one crossing or two crossing there's one
knot with three crossings there's one
knot is four crossings the two knots is
five crossings there are three knots
with six crossings and then it starts to
take off and really we get to a lot of
different knots when we have a big
number of crossings but let's first talk
about mathematical knots and it's not
maybe what you typically think is a knot
you see all kind of things that look oh
yeah yeah yeah these are definitely not
slight all kind of really beautiful
knots and of course here my shoelaces
form what already people would think a
knot now nothing of this is a
mathematical not because it has loose
ends if it has loose ends you can in
principle untie it and you can form a
different knot and so there's nothing
that you can say about these particular
nuts because nothing is topologically
locked in you can always undo the knots
and do something differently so the
ideal simplest possible mathematical nap
may be just a rubber band okay
well indeed mathematicians call this the
unknot or the trivial knots because
simply not very interesting but if you
take this rubber band this is oh I can
knot it and you try to make some kind of
and not into it and you stuff it through
itself and you do weird thing and it may
look very knotted well it's not any
different from what you started with
because I can go and undo the same thing
and it's still the same simple ring well
are there any non-trivial mathematical
knots that are not just opening up into
a single loop and yes there are for
instance this
implicit not is the trefoil knot it's
basically a closed loop as you can see
in this particular projection we can see
it has three crossings there's one
crossing here there's one crossing here
this one crossing there as I change this
knot around it may look quite different
and at some point it may have more than
just three crossings but it never has
fewer than three crossings it may be
quite irregular for instance you know
what is this thing certainly has a lot
of crossings but again we're looking for
the minimal number of crossings so we
try to untangle this and open it up as
much as we possibly can and if you're
patient enough and do that we can see oh
look three crossings as one crossing
layer there's another crossing there
there's another crossing bound there and
nothing I can do is get fewer than three
cross and of course I can twist it make
a fourth crossings bend it here like
next six or seven crossings but they're
looking for the minimal number and the
minimal number in this case happens to
be three crossings and with three
crossings for a mathematician these are
the same nuts
they're both the trefoil knot how do you
know when you've reached the minimum
number of crossings well you put your
finger on a very sore subject because
you don't now four simple knots the
personal question that these are the
simplest possibilities but say you're
going to twenty thirteen crossings or
something like that
you can't never be quite sure and as a
matter of fact it's still an open
problem to really have a very
complicated Gordian knot and figure out
what type of knot it is but because of
that because once you have the simplest
view of a knot in the way that's the one
that has the fewest crossings that tells
you what class you're in now if it
happens to be three crossings then
there's only one possible not the
trefoil actually it's not quite true
because if you were to make a mirror
image you could not deform this into its
own mirror image but mathematicians say
okay look we can mirror this thing so
they're not counting that separately now
can we make a knot with four crossings
here is such a nut and in this
particular projection you probably
see or crossings I saw one over here
there's one over on that side and then
this one in here and that one down there
and it turns out two things there's only
one type of knot is for crossings and
contrary to the trefoil this actually is
the same as its mirror image so I can
deform this into its mirror image as a
matter of fact let's look at that knot
in a little bit more detail here is the
classical image that you typically see
in a table of uh knots and that's why I
guess it's called figure right now
because you can see an obvious figure
eight in there it's not the only way and
the owl you see is all the time
one two three four crossings so all of
these are topologically the same thing
the one that I showed you before in wire
would be shown like this in this
particular diagram so you can see these
knots all look quite a bit different
really they're three-dimensional and so
people have made more three dimensional
rendering so it's something that's very
close to the first classical image that
we showed that simple diagram so this is
your figure eight knot and you can see
it looks yet quite different again but
in no projection will you ever see fewer
than four crossings and here we are this
is the real thing you know solid bronze
is a nice green patina done by Steve
Ramos in Eugene Oregon
absolutely watch out is heavy I love
that yeah Wow okay that's a foot what we
call that now foot that's a figure eight
knot and it's a for crossing knot and we
have seen the trefoil knot and we have
seen the figure eight knot now if you
look at the numbers below here the first
number here is a three here is a 4 they
indicate what that minimum number of
crossings is so that's known as the
crossing number the second number is
simply a serial index that tells you
this is the first of two possible kinds
of knots with five crossings they cannot
be transformed into one another a truly
different and it has been shown that
there's no third possibility so if you
have exactly five crossings as a minimal
number
either you have this knot or you have
that knot or they're mirror images as we
go to six crossings we now have three
possible options and they're all
different and they're just serial number
one two three in an arbitrary order by
the time we go to seven crossings we
have seven different possibilities so
that's the first classification of
mathematical knots you simply try to
figure out what's the minimum number and
when people first try to tabulate these
not tables own from hundred years ago
there were some tables originally for a
long time it was believed I think with
the eight crossing knots that they're
more one more but then actually to over
overlooked and others turned out to be
two plaits so it's really really
challenging you would think that maybe a
computer program can just take a view of
an arbitrary not an orbital diagram tell
you what not it is no that's
unfortunately not true it's true maybe
for the simple nuts that have you know
maybe up to ten or maybe even twelve
crossings but then it gets really really
hard because it's so difficult to know
how to deform you're not to first of all
get to the minimum number of crossings
and then how to reshape it in that shape
so it looks exactly like something that
you already have in your table people
have tried to come up with some
mathematical measures to try to describe
knots in in a formal way like an
algorithm or an equation absolutely and
so the the crossing number is certainly
one of those ways of representing a knot
another way to represent knots would be
that you're trying you flap you're not
as much as much as you can in in the
plane and like all of these are some two
and a half dimensional diagrams which
are playing the diagrams make sick leave
is just over on the crossings so assume
you're on the road and you're traveling
a wrong one of those paths and every
time you come to crossing you start
numbering them and your number visits
over and on them so on the first
crossing you go underneath call it
number one next crossing you may still
go on the number two then you go over
number three sometimes you come back to
some crossing off already beam maybe you
have an underpass now you're on the
overpass okay so at least that again but
you remember that underpass three is the
same as overpass 14 and then overpass
four is the same
as on the past 22 and that's another way
of describing how that North is really
linked people like John Horton Conway he
tries to chop up these not diagrams into
smaller pieces that have exactly four
strands coming out of it then and then
have a little bit of nuttiness inside
and group them together and link them
together and gradually build a complex
knock out of that and that led to
another
very formal description that can
describe any any knot you'd like to
describe so mr. Jones has come up with
some kind of a complicated polynomial
that describe knots as mr. Alexander and
has created an Alexander polynomial so
you think that you know is all this we
really know what's going on
unfortunately we still do not know
what's going on fact if you really
really complicated knots and you and ask
you are they the same first you try to
struggle find out you know what the
crossing number is of course if the
crossing number is different you know
they can not possibly be the same then
you struggle with the Jones polynomial
you struggle with the Alexander
polynomial if any one of these
polynomials is different we know the two
knots are different and there are two or
three more characteristics of knots but
even if all the known characteristics of
those two knots are exactly the same we
can still not be sure that they're
indeed the same knot so there's still an
open challenge to find a true descriptor
that really will will help to make it
quite unique when two knots are
different so mathematicians still don't
fully know what a knot is they Catholic
they haven't fully got well they know
what the knot is they just don't know if
I particular not exactly which label
they should assign to it and whether
type to complicate knots or truly
different or not here so this is me babe
this is not human day in Island no let's
assume this is either one of those loops
or is a circular DNA molecule that could
be a bacterial genome or it could be
just a naturally occurring plasmid you
are not a knot expert it's not just a
knot a file you are not a [ __ ]